let's take a quick look at how to use
cloud sequel with compute engine the
first step is to create a database go to
the sequel section and click create
instance and choose second generation
give your instance a name and then
choose the region and zone for your
instance you can now change the instance
type and the storage capacity don't
worry you can change these later if you
want to you can also ensure high
availability by creating failover
replicas and you can schedule backups
and maintenance windows as well click
create and in a few minutes
your instance should be created go to
the compute engine section and copy the
external IP address of your instance now
go back to the cloud sequel section and
click your instance here go to the
access control tab and click Add network
give it a name paste your IP address and
click done now hit save go to the users
tab and change the root password now go
back to the overview tab and copy the
ipv4 address you can now connect your
cloud sequel database just like any
other my sequel database